Active networks was way ahead of its time, and there was not a killer app to
justify this particular line of thought. Further, active networks focused more
on safety and less on performance, so in the 90s it seemed more like
a solution looking for a problem. But
difficulties with network management, rise of virtualization,
the right hardware support and data center and cloud computing have all
given active networks a new lease of life in the form of Software Defined
Networking or SDN for short. Specifically,
cloud computing promotes a model of utility
computing where multiple tenants, by that I
mean businesses, can host their respective corporate
networks simultaneously on the same computational
resources of a data center. Not that
this is going to ever happen but
imagine Coke and Pepsi, corporate networks running
on the same data center resources. What this means is there is a need
for perfect isolation, of the network traffic of one business from another,
even though each of the network traffic is flowing on the same
physical infrastructure. This calls for virtualization
of the physical network itself, and hence
the term, software defined networking. You will learn more about SDN if you
take a companion course on networking that is offered in this same program.